hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that today we'll take
the fine art of cinema and ask it to
engage in combat sure in actuality it's
a celebration of the two film legacies
of our respective stars though i do not
think they're here in person no neither
one of them but given that this here
program will focus on the greatness of
michelle yeo and lucy liu i think
competition is going to suit these two
a-listers just fine after all they can
do just about everything us audiences
love to see on the big screen action
drama romance and most importantly
pandas who know how to kung fu yes both
yo and lou are solid parts of that
franchise but that's just the tip of the
iceberg we got a james bond veteran
against the charlie's angel and an mcu
stalwart facing off with a kill bill
legend in one corner you have michelle
yo whose crazy rich filmography is
loaded with crouching tigers hidden
dragons and now 10 more rings in the
other corner is lucy liu who's done
everything from host saturday night live
to play in the paralegal sandbox and she
even helped some fella named sherlock
solve mysteries in fact the only thing
these ladies can't do is both win today
i know i know it's a very tough call
that your definitely not expert panel of
judges will have to make i know they're
not experts because i'm the judge
and the jury and pretty much both
lawyers it's my courtroom and it's all
for fun here's how we'll determine a
winner round one box office round two
tomato meter slash audience score round
three iconic rolls round four memorable
moments
and then we'll do a wild card round that
sources tell me could involve fight
scenes or dance sequences maybe a
musical number your methodologies are
antiquated and weak really i'm just
excited to give you all the background
on these two stellar stars and how they
conquered hollywood and the worldwide
box office it's lucy liu who i first saw
on the big screen in charlie's angels
versus michelle yo who i think i was
introduced to in one of the super cop
flicks yeah we're gonna celebrate them
both but coming out of the gate with
movies like those they're always down to
brawl on the silver or the small screen
let's get it on round one box office
ah the movie theater that magical place
where folks from all walks of life can
sit down relax and ingest thousands of
empty calories while watching
action-packed epics uplifting romantic
comedies and everything in between and
in the case of michelle yo and lucy wu
plenty of people across the globe have
done just that and have been since the
mid-1980s when yo first exploded onto
the silver screen
and for a preemptive bouncing act here's
how i can level the field of play as
fairly as possible since we don't have
accurate box office data for some of
yo's early cinematic fare i also will
not include lucy lou's extensive tv work
in this round her starring roles in ally
mcbeal and elementary certainly would
help her case in terms of ratings but
she may not even need all those hit
shows after all she burst onto the scene
as an angel courtesy of some shy fella
named chuck the two thousand mega hit
charlie's angels was not lose first roll
but it was her biggest hit at the time
and after being featured in the mel
gibson's success payback which earned
161 million dollars worldwide angels
would rake in
259 million and the sequel full throttle
would add another 227 million dollars
but lou was just getting warmed up the
oscar winning chicago did over 300
million dollars and then the kung fu
panda trilogy soared to a combined haul
of 1.8 billion
like in dollars who could possibly
compete with that uh michelle yo because
she's in the mcu and pops into kung fu
panda too as well but before those
monster hits yo contributed mightily to
franchises like supercop and made quite
an impression alongside pierce brosnan's
james bond and tomorrow never dies which
would go on to take in 339 million
dollars worldwide crouching tiger hidden
dragon was a phenomenon upon its release
in 2000 and cashed into the tune of 213
million bucks hits like mechanic
resurrection and memoirs of a geisha
each tacked on over 100 million in
cheddar to her sparkling resume then the
mcu stuff those movies tend to do okay
at the box office and before being a big
part of shang chi's 417 million dollar
earnings yo played starhawk in the
second guardians of the galaxy flick
which made him easily 869 million in fun
cash register jingle noises the mummy
tomb of the dragon emperor grossed over
400 million dollars however lucy luke
can counter with the resounding success
of both kill bill volumes which combined
for over 300 million dollars at the
multiplex if it sounds like we'll have a
lot of fun action movies to discuss
later at length it's because we will and
y'all don't even know the half of it yet
but when you factor in hit rom-coms like
crazy rich asians michelle yo starts to
pull away her combined box office total
again just from the movies that we have
data for is a superb 3.75 billion
dollars however lucy lou is right on her
heels as her talking pictures have done
3.5 billion bucks so where is the
separation well it all comes down to
movie average joe's films taking about
209 million dollars per outing lewis
accumulate 146 million on average now
let's take a step back here any of you
all have 146 million dollars lying
around i did but i spent it leasing my
ford fusion it's a sizeable number for
any star and that doesn't factor in lucy
lou's tv ratings which skyrocketed
thanks to multiple hit shows but
michelle yo's unreal 200 million dollar
plus per film average is just too much
competition here and she gets on the
board first it's yo one lose zero round
two tomato meter slash audience score
and now we arrive at that round that can
factor in all of yo's filmography as
well as lose tv shows like an ally
mcbeal or an elementary so let's first
head over to the tomato meter and see
how the critics felt about some of those
movies that did such buffo box office in
round one and i see some freshness wu's
tinkerbell outings are at worst 90
percent and at best a perfect 100
percent meanwhile the diversity of
michelle yo's filmography is on full
display at the top the high-flying
martial artistry of crouching tiger
hidden dragon is at 98 percent comic
book extravaganza shong cheese at 91
percent and the heartwarming comedy
crazy rich asians is at an even 90
every kung fu panda and super cop movie
on these two resumes is fresh as well
and yo's james bond outing isn't oh so
close to fresh at 56
unfortunately for her not every sequel
she's done has faired as well as the big
cuddly panda movie the mechanic the
mummy and even a crouching tiger second
entry are all well below fresh and bible
on a d it clocks in as her basement at
seven percent well yeah if you think
seven percent is low you have not met
ballistic x versus sever the movie has
some redeeming action intensity that
might help lucy lue out in a later round
but here it's at zero percent and a
friendly reminder that zero percent
doesn't mean that no critics reviewed it
it's that none of them dug it that's as
friendly as i can put it charlie's
angels full throttle landed at a rotten
42 percent but the first film was fresh
at a bill and ted approved 69 percent
all told it's another close race here
michelle yo's tomato meter average is
fresh at 60 percent per film lucy liu
just behind with a 55 per movie average
on the audience score side of the ledger
the tables turn slightly in favor of lou
her average climbs to the border of
freshville at 59 percent and yo dips
slightly south into rottentown at 56
percent per film so how does one make a
call one way or another for michelle yo
or lucy lou in this round the tv box is
the ace in the hole now most of you all
have those fancy 4k ones mine's 85
inches i measured it twice but back when
ally mcbeal premiered we were still
glued to our fat back tv sets
we should really stop fat shaming those
old televisions they didn't know any
better it's bad enough that they're
obsolete now we got to toss name
grenades their way look i love you big
bone tvs you still make sega genesis
graphics look dope anywho if ali mcbeal
60 fresh average on the tomato meter
isn't quite enough to sway me towards
giving lucy lou a victory in this round
her next hit show might elementary the
modern day telling of sherlock holmes
and her dr joan watson ran for seven
seasons and averages 95 percent on the
tomato meter and that yi children is
what we call a knockout blow for this
round anyway lucy lou gets the w here
and we got us a tied ball game at one
point a piece
oliver
yes i do
be a deer and take care of that round
three iconic rolls
oh it's a good match-up brewing with
these two worldwide stars but before we
get to the rolls that made them
international sensations let's take a
walk down memory lane with michelle yeo
and lucy liu all right honestly it's
just gonna be me doing the walk with you
but uh we'll be talking about them and
there's no actual walking involved so
you can stay on the couch or wherever
you are if you're watching this on a
treadmill
props to you notch the incline up a few
and let's get strolling for michelle yo
her martial arts mastery and acting
chops began as a deviation from her
chosen career path she was accepted into
the royal dance academy in london and
was pursuing her destiny of becoming a
ballerina when she suffered a brutal
back injury her instructor and principal
assured her that there's other ways to
use physicality to express oneself and
soon after the 1983 miss malaysia winner
was studying martial arts and even
appeared in a commercial with some
fellow named jackie chan like chan yo
impressed even the toughest of boys with
her combat acumen and her ability to do
her own stunts she won rave reviews for
an early role in yes madam with american
martial arts badass cynthia rothrock and
her new path was clear you worked with
jackie chan and left an impression on
the most famous lead star stuntman of
all time when the two teamed up for the
super cop films her work as inspector
jessica yang showed the world that not
only could she punch kick and have a
great time doing it just like jackie she
could also act her role in the bond film
tomorrow never dies would become a
scintillating introduction to american
audiences not only was she the first
chinese bond girl she might have been
the best brawler of them all and that
includes any of you boys playing double
07. lucy lou's career path was markedly
different from yo's as lou was born in
the jackson heights area of queens in
new york her parents came from shanghai
and beijing met in taiwan and began a
family once arriving in the united
states lucy studied martial arts and
acting and when she was a senior at the
university of michigan she landed the
lead role in their production of alice
in wonderland did desmond howard play
the mad hatter the college football joke
he won the heisman folks after booking
some small movie and tv roles she got a
big career boost when ali mcbeal came
around she was so good in her audition
for another role that the creators made
the character of wing woo specifically
for her and eventually she would earn an
emmy nomination for the part big screen
blockbusters like the charlie's angels
franchise arrived in 2000 and alongside
drew barrymore and cameron diaz lou
cemented herself as a tinseltown star if
the angels gave us glimpses into lou's
fighting ability kill bill solidified it
on a worldwide stage her role as oren
ishii also known as cottonmouth is
iconic not just for her sword-wielding
magnificence but for the intense
emotional depth her character stirs in
the audience fun fact your simpleton
host had somehow never seen either kill
bill because i'm a simpleton now that's
been rectified and it's just so awesome
for michelle yo crouching tiger hidden
dragon was a showcase for her uncanny
martial arts magic and also proved on a
worldwide stage how great of an actor
she is for the role of yu shu lin she
did many of her own stunts a common
theme throughout her career leading
right up to her battle scenes in the
mcu's chongqi
other films highlighting yo's soaring
combat antics include reign of assassins
and for dramatic chops check out luke
bassan's 2011 film the lady yo revealed
yet another side of herself in the
blockbuster hit crazy rich asians where
she plays matriarch eleanor young with a
quiet intensity that adds depth to the
rom-com feel of the film lucy lou could
have rested on her walls as an angel or
a vicious warrior from kill bill but
from there her career options allowed
her to explore even more avenues within
hollywood including another big time tv
show as dr joan watson in the highly
rated elementary she's the grounded
logic foil for johnny lee miller's
eccentric modern day sherlock that guy
was in hackers anyone remember that
nothing better than 90s internet movies
oh we were so young it's a tough round
to call here simply because both ladies
have left their mark in hollywood in
multiple ways but when i consider the
breadth of lucy lou's reach from
charlie's angels to kill bill to a
hugely popular tv series and as
everyone's favorite viper from the kung
fu panda trilogy she gets the slight
edge today i could wake up tomorrow and
change my mind and tomorrow never dies
it's the bond movie if the point goes to
lucy blue and now it's lucy 2 michelle
won do you have any idea the scandal
this would have caused round four
memorable moments and now it's time for
my favorite round thus far because we
get to take the gloves off i already did
that give the stunt doubles the day off
and sink our teeth into some of the best
action sequences cinema has seen in the
last four decades but before we get some
sweet punches kicks and glass shattering
death defying leaping let's warm up with
some softer gentler poignant moments all
right we don't have many of those simply
because even in a non-action role like
crazy rich asians for yo we feel her
presence and the command that eleanor
has over the room take our first meeting
with her we're introduced to this
dynamic at the same time that girlfriend
rachel is and there's no question who's
in charge of this family and for lou
besides her extensive work in television
procedurals like elementary don't forget
about her smaller part as kitty in
chicago it's not much more than a cameo
but it's impactful nonetheless okay
let's have some action fun here the
flowing kimono look for ishii in kill
bill took a minute for lucy lu to master
but once she did the fight scenes had
followed surpassed even what martial
arts fanboy quentin tarantino could have
imagined yet for all of that intensity
what struck me most watching the battle
sequences was the quiet mastery of the
samurai sword technique that's evident
in her final fight scene for a more
violent kinetic look check out the
badassery from the house of blue leaves
which is now how i want to decorate my
apartment charlie's angels allowed lou
to reign free and perform just about
every move in the action film playbook
there's a legendary tussle with the thin
man and in the sequel full throttle
there's a flamethrower that would even
make the boys from contra blush you see
how she's using it yeah y'all are gonna
need another 30 lives to get through
that but perhaps the best display of
lucy lou's skills is from a barely seen
horribly reviewed 1990s effort called x
versus sever it did her no favors in the
box office or the tomato meter round but
here it's a gigantic feather in her cap
she trained for over three months five
to six days a week enhancing her martial
arts tactics and nailing the
choreography and hearing that just makes
you hate how good the movie is not i
remember seeing the poster for it i was
already smitten with antonio banderas
from desperado and then it just
disappeared from theaters in like three
days but lucy woo and her kick ass free
is more than enough of a reason to check
it out i ran it don't uh you don't need
to buy it michelle yo began her martial
arts career being doubted by the guys
who worked at her dojo and that early
1980s time frame is probably the last
time anyone would scoff at her entering
a gym
or when she's doing a flip or suspending
from a rooftop and crushing glass and
skulls in the process
when most american and i guess british
audiences first met her she was the
toughest part of a jimmy bond film
because she had an absurdly awesome
motorcycle chase what we didn't know yet
is that that's child's play for michelle
she literally jumped a motorcycle onto a
train in supercomp also known as police
story 3. and did i mention the train was
moving at the time it even floored
co-star jackie chan who's pretty good at
doing stunts his damn self yes madam has
loads of impressive sequences and
michelio and cynthia rothrock kicking
ass and taking names is just a hoot and
2010's reign of assassins features an
unforgettable bank brawl but enough
preamble let's get right to possibly the
goat when it comes to memorable moments
of mayhem crouching tiger hidden dragon
has one magnificent sequence after
another including a scene where yo dual
wields swords and then switches to a
spear and then there's like a a hook
contraption is there any weapon she has
not mastered this jaw dropping action
piece choreographed by the
mythologically great yen woo ping is a
banquet of quickness poise power and
grace crouching tiger is rightfully
celebrated for furthering the artistry
of martial arts on the big screen and to
this day i'm not sure anything has
surpassed it chongqi proved that
michelle yo can still hang with the best
of them and for this round it acts as
the closer both lucy lou and yo have
forged careers chock full of great
moments and while today i focused on the
best action scenes their genre-defying
careers will get some shine in the next
round for moments it's lucy liu who's a
worthy competitor but yo just has too
much on that resume to refuse she gets
the point and we're all tied up heading
into the final round and now it's time
for the wild card round versatility
through four hard-fought rounds our two
stars have proven how talented they are
in not just one field of cinema or a
tiny section of blockbuster they can
fill up an entire red box with diverse
roles and successful performances inside
and outside the world of action
adventure but to take home the ultimate
prize which is what do we have a trophy
no a crown i will we'll get you
something they're going to have to show
off their versatility on the big and
small screen and we'll see who takes the
cake ooh we should give out cake every
show
just because i've already covered lots
of cool action that doesn't mean we
can't recap some of that awesomeness
right now michelle yo made her mark in
high flying flicks like super cop and
tamara never dies and her unique
abilities have been showcased in
everything from crouching tiger hidden
dragon to shang chi lucy wu is the
singular most important reason that
charlie's angels were successful in any
of their missions with all due respect
to cameron and drew and bill murray and
bernie mac and if kill bill may be her
finest moment in displaying her rare
fighting ability roles like agent sever
and yeah viper from kung fu panda proved
that she can do it time and time again
so if we're looking for versatility the
question is what other tools are on that
swiss army knife for yo it's her
graceful moves that aren't limited to
combat she can do comedy as well
obviously crazy rich asians is a huge
hit and she's some understated humor
there but she also displayed a more
overt sense of comedic timing in wing
chun where she goes toe to toe with
donnie yen yeah there's cool action in
there too but the comedic elements are
prominent and put the breadth of talent
harbored by both performers on full
display lou didn't just beat up baddies
and charlie's angels the big screen
reboot became a franchise because their
fun thrill rides filled with chuckles
along the way ally mcbeal and elementary
further show off the chemistry she can
have with just about anyone in any
setting doesn't matter if it's
interoffice politics or solving
mysteries on the streets of new york i'd
add kung fu panda to the pile when it
comes to working as a team and let's not
also forget she's great as a princess in
shanghai noon will and you have no issue
handling the dramatic weight of a scene
as well lewis watson having to anchor
holmes's issues is more than enough
testament and yo's performance in films
like the lady and memoirs of a geisha
can't be forgotten one of the most
impressive aspects of both actresses is
their ability to convey so much of that
dramatic intensity within the context of
a fight scene now dummies like me may
show up with a bag of mr redenbacher's
finest corn to witness glorious battle
but if the flick i'm watching is a
crouching tiger or a kill bill i'm gonna
leave having witnessed so much more from
an emotional standpoint and now the
worst part of my day i have to make a
decision to go with either michelle yo
or lucy lou because the show can't end
in a tie
but can it can we just say they're both
great then i can go home there's like 30
producers in here and none of whom will
validate my parking apparently the show
is called versus for a reason both
deserve the nod but if i'm forced to
pick a winner here's the tiebreaker to
me and yes madam michelle yo does her
own stunts including a sequence when
she's suspended upside down from a
balcony and headbutts a glass panel into
tiny pieces it's real and she nailed it
in one take
while taking down an array of evildoers
oh and she did that motorcycle to train
thing that made jackie chan knock his
knees don't try any of that at home kids
both performers are amazing on whatever
size screen they're being viewed on but
today the w by the slightest of margins
goes to michelle yo she wins the wild
card round and thus the match now if any
of you sons have
got anything else to say
now the [ __ ] time
and that's why these calls are so tough
some of these episodes are fun because
they're easy to see who's gonna win did
anyone think the simpsons was gonna lose
the family guy raise your hand if you
thought robocop set a chance against
terminator but then you get michelle yo
versus lucy liu and the fun isn't in how
easy the match is to judge it's how much
research and re-watching and fact
fighting we all get to do to celebrate
both magnificent talent and again i
can't stress this enough i was late to
the party on kill bill my bad i hadn't
seen not a one volume and now 20 years
later
i don't know what i was waiting for
thanks for tuning in today kiddos
remember this is just my humble take if
you have a favorite flick or sequence
from michelle and or lucy hit me up
anytime on social media at mark ellis
live and be sure to keep tabs right here
at rotten tomatoes for all the latest
from michelle yo lucy liu and everyone
else in hollywood they all live in this
matrix in addition to whatever other
palatial estates they may enjoy well for
me it's back to the valley i think i'll
take the forward fusion because
motorcycles terrify me even if they're
not jumping onto trains i won't even set
foot on a bird scooter all right see
y'all next time and buckle up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]